welcome to oversight you're now part of
the frontline that protects our country
from terrorists predators illegal
immigrants and benefit fraudsters thank
you for volunteering oversight is
contracted by the government to operate
their automated filter the filter looks
at every bit of Internet traffic that
travels through the UK when it finds
something suspicious
it'll pass it on to you or one of the
thousands of volunteers like yourself
while you log into your dashboard
you'll see a list of possible incidents
click on any to investigate is this a
joke you email between friends or a
serious incident worth reporting to the
police you've got the tools to find out
you can read the subject lines of emails
the websites they visited information
from social networks location history
credit card purchases and information
about their friends and family if you
need to access more personal information
like the contents of their emails and
documents or the individual web pages
they've read click to apply for a search
warrant
it'll normally be granted within 15 to
30 seconds in many cases this isn't
necessary 34% of UK adults have opted in
to our clearway program giving you
immediate access to help prevent crime
if you find someone too difficult to
investigate don't waste time
immediately escalate to a supervisor we
find that deliberately hiding your
tracks is usually a sign of criminal
activity thanks to our agreements with
oversight sister companies around the
world that same information is now
available about citizens of over 70
countries if you speak a second language
you may sometimes be assigned to
jurisdictions outside the UK legal and
social restrictions in other countries
may differ from your own remember to be
impartial and to follow the instructions
on screen and finally don't tell your
friends that you're part of our team our
filtering systems are effective because
they're universal there really is no way
to avoid them and you never know who
might be part of oversight including
that person you're bragging to so thank
you once again for volunteering with
your help we can keep ourselves our
children and our world safe
you